Die Grinsekatze,
die Teeparty,
die Herzkönigin,
der Märzhase
und der verrückte Hutmacher –
sie alle stammen aus der
Geschichte „Alice im Wunderland“,
einem der bekanntesten
Kinderbücher der Welt.
Das Victoria and Albert Museum in London
widmet der berühmten Erzählung
eine ganze Ausstellung,
die den kulturellen Einfluss
der Geschichte unter die Lupe nimmt.
Warum Alice so eine Faszination ausübt,
lässt sich kaum beantworten.
Es ist ein so großes, weltweites Phänomen.
Das Buch wurde 1865 veröffentlicht,
und wir sind immer noch davon begeistert.
Mit dieser Ausstellung versuchen
wir die Frage zu beantworten,
wie und warum Alice zu diesem
Phänomen geworden ist –
nicht nur in der Literatur, sondern überall,
auch in Film, Kunst, Design, Fotografie,
Mode, Wissenschaft, Mathematik.
In jedem Lebensbereich lässt sich
irgendwo ein Bezug zu Alice finden.
Ihren Ursprung hat die Kindergeschichte
im Jahr 1862 im britischen Oxford.
Inspiriert von den wissenschaftlichen
Errungenschaften der damaligen Zeit,
erfindet der Universitätsdozent
Charles Dodgson
die Erzählung für die
damals 10-jährige Alice Liddell,
die Tochter eines Freundes.
Drei Jahre später veröffentlicht er die
fantasievolle Geschichte als Buch
unter dem Pseudonym „Lewis Carroll”:
der Beginn eines Mythos.
Die Reise von Alice ist so eindrucksvoll.
Sie ist eine sehr willensstarke Heldin.
Sie ist mutig, neugierig,
stur und abenteuerlustig.
Wir können von den Botschaften
des Buches immer noch lernen.
Es ist immer noch inspirierend.
Sie ist ein unglaublich
ermutigendes und starkes Vorbild.
Das Buch wurde unzählige Male verfilmt:
darunter der US-amerikanische
Walt-Disney-Klassiker aus dem Jahr 1951
oder die Version des US-amerikanischen
Regisseurs Tim Burton aus dem Jahr 2010.
Die Figuren und Erlebnisse
der zeitlosen Kindergeschichte
bieten schier endlose Möglichkeiten
für Interpretationen.
Das war auch die Herausforderung
für den renommierten britischen
Bühnenbildner Tom Piper,
hier zu Hause in seinem Büro.
Er hat die Räume
der gesamten Ausstellung gestaltet.
Ich fand es zugleich schwierig und aufregend,
meine eigenen Vorstellungen
zu dem Buch zu entwickeln –
wie die Idee mit dem Pier am Meer,
der sich in eine Raupe verwandelt.
Ich habe einen Pier gezeichnet,
mit spindeldürren Beinen,
der sich aufrichtet und zur Raupe wird.
Es hat Spaß gemacht, etwas zu gestalten,
das es so nicht im Buch gibt,
aber davon inspiriert wurde.
Um die Reise in Alices Welt einzuleiten,
orientiert sich der Designer zum Beispiel am
viktorianischen Streben nach Wissen.
Er kreiert eine Bibliothek,
die zum Leben erwacht und in der Buchseiten
durch den Raum schweben.
Ich habe tatsächlich alle Mittel verwendet,
die ich auch im Theater einsetze,
um eine Art immersive Welt in der
Ausstellung zu erschaffen.
Ich hoffe, dass die Leute sich
wirklich so fühlen,
als wären sie in den Kaninchenbau gefallen,
und nach einem fantastischen Erlebnis
wieder herauskommen –
voller Fragen vielleicht –
und hoffentlich auch staunen.
Zurück im Museum:
Von Surrealismus und psychedelischer Kunst
der 1960er-Jahre
über Politisches bis hin zu Fotografie,
Mode und Bühnenkostümen –
die Geschichte von Alice im Wunderland
hat fast alle Bereiche der Kultur inspiriert
und beeinflusst.
Die Zukunft von Alice ist völlig offen.
Ich bin mir sicher,
dass sich das Phänomen
immer weiter entwickeln wird.
Und ich finde es aufregend,
dass wir Quantenphysiker haben, die sich die
Theorien im Buch anschauen,
Modedesigner wie Iris van Herpen,
die sich mit den Theorien
von Raum und Zeit beschäftigen,
um die Grenzen des Designs zu sprengen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt,
was noch passieren wird.
Bereits heute ist es in der Ausstellung
dank modernster Technik möglich,
Charaktere aus dem Buch zu treffen.
Mit einer Virtual-Reality-Brille
können Besucherinnen und Besucher
die Herzkönigin
bei einer Partie Krocket schlagen.